et on va ouvrir la page politique à
présent avec cette photo parue dans le
journal paris match oui l'hebdomadaire
qui publie vous le voyez en couverture
cette photo d'eric zemmour avec sa
compagne c'est sa conseillère en
communication
sarah knafo qui dirige sa campagne même
si on le rappelle eric zemmour n'est pas
encore officiellement candidat
il a décidé de porter plainte contre le
journal pour atteinte à la vie privée et
on va en parler avec nicolas jules vidal
justement c'est l'édito politique de la
matinale
[Musique]
bonjour nicolas bonjour à tous les deux
bonjour sa fait plaisir de voeux de vous
avoir sur ce plateau de si bonne heure
alors eric zemmour semble de plus en
plus en campagne
en cette rentrée que doit-on en penser
mais on peut dire qu'avec ses photos
parues dans paris match la campagne
finalement est officiellement lancée
eric zemmour on l'a vu bien entendu il
est là il était sur ces photos hier
matin et il ira après midi et
effectivement ça pose un problème mais
il faut quand même dire qu'à un moment
donné la campagne aussi commencent en
dessous de la ceinture ça c'est évident
et eric zemmour en fait ils les rendent
tous fous il les rend complètement
zinzin et ce matin bien je vais vous le
dire on va pas faire dans la dentelle 40
à vivre une présidentielle historique
dans quelques mois on s'épargnera de
décoder les calculs politiques mesquins
fait sur le tableau weleda des petits
arrangements électoraux car nous ne
sommes pas là ce matin chers amis pour
meubler le silence avec un décryptage du
café du commerce version 6e
arrondissement coincé entre eux deux
bulletins météo alors chez les
républicains chez les écolos et au ps ça
rende compte sérieusement comme on
disait chez moi ça fait 30 ans que les
français en ont tant besoin comme quoi
les français je présente une présente il
se présente nous nous présentons on se
présente tous ensemble quitte à se
prendre une grosse gifle tout en tirant
la courte paille de nos mandats locaux
parce qu'en fait qu'il faudrait pas tout
perdre il n'y a pas que la
présidentielle dans la vie et les
indemnités d'élue hébert franchement
c'est vachement important mais cette
campagne présidentielle ressemble à une
grosse galette des rois et la faiblesse
et qui bat la fef c'est eric zemmour
bien sûr
mais pourtant nicolas il semble normal
que les partis se mettent en ordre de
bataille en vue de 2022 bien entendu
mais ne sous-estimé pas le syndrome de
la fesse rouge qui en jette plus d'un
pour cette campagne présidentielle car
au final les candidats déclarés sont
déjà très très nombreux et ils se
tiennent par la barbichette et refuse
cela sheila graves notamment chez les
républicains et chez les écolos et cela
au nom ça s'appelle comment ça s'appelle
bijoux donne en mille un magali olivier
ça s'appelle les primaires vous savez
c'est un peu comme si le salon
l'agriculture avait décidé de simplifier
son organisation et d'exposer uniquement
des burgers et des tranches de baguette
c'est moins de boulot et cela
al'avantage d'être prêt en cinq minutes
donc pour les primaires c'est pareil on
se présente qui a pas réfléchir juste
ressortir du frigo le programme périmé
depuis cinq ans et tout cela c'était
sans compter sur eric premier monsieur
11% le baron noir à deux chiffres qui ne
m'aiment pas encore candidat je veux
bien entendu parler chers amis ce matin
du cyrano de bergerac de la politique
qui dit haut ce que les autres s'empêche
de pensée a mis en examen n'est pas
encore officiellement candidat alors
pourquoi occupe-t-il autant l'espace
médiatique et bien c'est grâce à une
triste galipes pas des ragas l'hyper se
fait penser à un truc du csa qui a tenté
de lui couper le sifflet du tout et le
bec et de lui fermer la marmite alors
qu'il officiait chez nos confrères de
ces news et bien manque de pot eric
zemmour est absolument partout même à la
une de paris match vous l'avez dit
interview des bars entretien même ces
rencontres imaginer littéraire son film
et notamment à toulon où il était
poursuivi par un gros et 5 juin liste de
perche et de micros alors eric zemmour
prend sa revanche en clair c'est lui qui
fixe les règles mais la question de fond
est la suivante pourquoi eric zemmour
polémiste qui passionne autant qu ils
énervent va imposer le rythme les thèmes
cette campagne présidentielle parce que
zemmour est un puncheur qui tape là où
ça fait mal pendant que les autres font
des bras dans l'eau croupie delà des
pistes les républicains en plastique
qu'on partage ou pas ces idées eric
zemmour a compris depuis longtemps les
grands sujets de préoccupation des
millions de français auxquels il apporte
son analyse et ses réponses en parle en
cash et ce qui risque d'arriver que sa
candidature c'est le retour du vote
d'adhésion et ça c'est important terminé
le vote de contestation sur lequel
certes marine le pen avec ses tongs fluo
et lorsque vous avez en face de vous les
mollahs sont républicains
contorsionniste où les écolos qui prend
de l'insurrection des bégonias où la
révolte des pupilles des peupliers
version wac attitude eh bien ça pèse pas
lourd
même pas des socialistes qui sont
devenus un grand plan social à eux seuls
quant à emmanuel macron il a retrouvé
les clés du coffre et brandissant stylo
pour faire des chèques à tout le monde
par contre 1 par contre si vous avez été
oubliée adressez vous à l'elysée car si
le moment ou jamais d'avoir le chèque de
son côté eric zemmour remplit les salles
explose les ventes de chacun de ses
livres alors oui ça énerve ça agace et
ça rend folle la concurrence mais michel
barnier baron de bruxelles devient
souverainiste imaginez c'est pour dire
mais comment expliquer tout de même
qu'eric zemmour qui n'est pas encore
candidat bouscule les pronostics agit de
la classe politique a bien lu mais en
réalité c'est assez simple eric zemmour
remet au goût du jour le programme du
rpr dans le temps cette ligne directrice
enterrée par nicolas sarkozy en 2007 qui
a coulé l'ump le l'époque qui a sabordé
les leurs aujourd'hui sur les sujets
brûlants de la sécurité l'identité et de
la souveraineté sans parler de l'audio
de traité de lisbonne en 2008 on s'en
souvient tous sarkozy a littéralement
coupé la droite classique de millions de
français qui se sont sentis trahis alors
que lui se vanter pendant ce temps on
peut la presque avec carla c'était du
sérieux tel un ado prépubère pour qui le
chanteur roch voisine faisait battre son
petit coeur et bien aujourd'hui qu'on le
veuille ou non eric zemmour est en train
de dynamiter la présidentielle ainsi que
la légitimité de la classe politique
dans son ensemble car entre lui et des
millions de francs ces chers amis c'est
du sérieux pour finir l'auteur philippe
murray qui n'avait pas besoin de
fanfaronner sortie top comme certains
écrivent et je cite la liberté de pensée
a toujours été une sorte de maladie mais
nous voilà guéris ne pas débiter le
catéchisme collectif d'emblée est un
signe de folie à méditer car les
français eux n'ont pas dit leur dernier
mot on verra cela merci beaucoup nicolas
galipettes ça me faisait penser à quoi
mct icarly tourner deux lettres van laer
consonnes et voyelles
merci beaucoup s'est elle l'édito
politique de nicolas vidal ce matin